hey everyone welcome to Yesi TV where
you can find weekly videos on minimalism
and healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life today we're gonna
be talking about bullies critics haters
what do you do about them today I'm
gonna share with you five ways that I
overcame bullying I used to think of
myself as a caterpillar you know the
green squishy ones but did you know
these gooey things become butterflies
I'm not talking about a makeover I'm
talking about finding your true
potential and what you can actually
accomplish so this leads me to way
number one the critics and the haters
they're going to be everywhere we can't
escape it but if you're going to
overcome it the first and foremost thing
that you have to do is love and accept
yourself flaws and all bullies tend to
target people that they feel are weaker
than them because it makes them feel
more powerful and better about
themselves it's like the leader of the
pack mentality and one just has to be
the Alpha and they'll do and say
whatever to get there the worst thing
you can do is back down scared because
you've just shown them they're the Alpha
I've always admired my husband because
he doesn't back down from anyone that
wants to pick a fight whether they're
bigger than him or not but he had
military training I didn't
I'm wimpy so what do I do develop
confidence no matter what you've heard
before confidence is not something
you're born with it's something you
develop in my video how I overcame
social anxiety I touch on this if you
watch enough of my videos you will see
that I am a goofy weirdo but for years I
tried to hide and change this
personality trying to be like the other
girls that just seems so effortlessly
poised and gracious and beautiful and I
wasn't like that if confidence doesn't
come easy to you it's okay it certainly
didn't for me either
but know that you can develop this and
it's
with learning to love yourself and
accept yourself with your flaws moving
on to number two analyze who the
criticism is coming from when people ask
me about my goals for the future and I
mentioned that I'm actively working on
becoming an entrepreneur in real estate
to retire early then look at me like I'm
a nut job they make all sorts of
negative comments some people don't
believe that it's going to happen and
they try to crush my dream some people
get jealous and they try to guilt me or
be rude saying things like must be easy
for you our act as though things have
been handed to me on a silver platter so
the way I handle these critics and dream
crushers is I asked myself two questions
do they either know enough about me or
do they know enough about the topic or
whatever it is that we're talking about
to actually be able to criticize if it's
my family or friends okay yes maybe they
need criterion number one maybe they
know me but maybe they're trying to keep
me from accomplishing my dreams or my
goals because they're afraid of seeing
me fail maybe they don't know what
they're talking about number three ask
yourself is there truth to their
criticism and if so what can you change
if you are on youtube laughed and
commented about a mistake that I had
made on some of my videos I had two
options I could either a put myself down
be upset but do nothing or B get over it
and actually work to fix the problem I
like option B you can't change the past
and you can't change who you are but if
there's some truth to what they're
saying even if it's in a hurtful way try
to separate from the MOE
that you're feeling and just analyzed
the facts in middle school home middle
school when one day in gym class my
shirt accidentally flipped up the kids
laughed at me because I had a muffin top
and I realized yeah I had a muffin top
it was hurtful that they laughed it was
humiliating but I slowly started to
change my diet negative criticism just
sucks and sometimes it's even worse
because the way it's given is in the
negative way it's in a hurtful way for
me I remember that day in gym class like
it was yesterday
sure I felt humiliated but when I was
able to distance myself from the emotion
and just analyze them max there was kind
of a sense of relief to know that there
was something that I could change that
this didn't have to be that way so you
have to be open to negative criticism
but do not forget number one because you
have to love and accept yourself in the
process but also in number four do not
ever change for anyone else when I
decided I was gonna change my diet I
decided it for myself because I wanted
myself to feel good about me not because
I wanted them to acknowledge the fact
that I no longer had a muffin top if
someone is criticizing you for something
that's out of your control or something
physical something that you can't change
like where you're from or your skin
color don't give them the time of day
when guys in school laughed at me for
having hairy monkey arms I realized at
some point
sure I could constantly wax but if I did
that I would be doing it for them not
because I really cared hey I'm okay with
being fuzzy I have one eyebrow higher
than the other but I'm not gonna have
plastic surgery just to make them happy
there are certain things that you can or
should change but if there's something
about you that you're comfortable with
or that you like and other people don't
forget them that's their problem not
yours number five learn to last
sometimes
did I say that there's always going to
be someone to criticize you it's as if
the more you climb up the more they just
have to tear you down because they're
afraid you might accomplish something
that they're not doing some people just
aren't worth paying attention to that
person that cuts you off on the road and
make you jam on your brakes they just
went about their day while you might
still be feeling that anger that anxiety
that you want to get back at them you're
only doing yourself a disservice so
learn to yes feel that initial rush of
adrenaline get past it and just laugh if
there's gonna be anything redundant in
all of my videos it's stress triggers
inflammation which triggers disease
repeat with me you can't allow that
person who is meaningless in your life
who's not of any service to you but
rather a disservice to cause you harm
so don't let them get under your skin
and if laughing is weird maybe maybe you
can do like a maniacal laugh like whoa
and for sticking to the end my bonus tip
for you is find ways to develop
confidence this can be things like
positive affirmations and positive
visualization this means you constantly
repeat to yourself positive things that
you want to believe about yourself or
that you want to be able to accomplish
and your brain will start to hardwire
these neural connections to actually
believing it and actually try to carry
out these situations it can mean
gratitude and gratefulness the more you
start to give and the more you start to
be grateful about what you have the less
negative you're going to be about the
things that you're not doing or not
accomplishing my favorite and what
actually helped me with social anxiety
is the Helen Keller approach do
something that scares you every day
until you're doing something
so I challenge you to attack at the
bullies and the critics starting within
yourself and let me know which bonus tip
you're gonna try that's it for today
guys if you liked this video please give
it a thumbs up and subscribe so that you
won't miss out on my weekly videos I
thank you so much for watching and I
can't wait to see you in the next one so
I challenge you to miss my challenge